hello everyone and welcome to the next
Monte Carlo simulator video in the last
video we created our dice and in this
video we want to create our better so
eventually we'll have some more
sophisticated betters but for now we're
just going to start with an extremely
simple better and even this simple
better has a lot to show us about odds
and outcomes and all of that so we have
a lot to learn from this simple better
with that the next thing that we need to
do really is we're going to edit this
roll dice function so right now it just
returns the roll but actually let's go
ahead and just have it return since
really what we're looking for here is
yeah we care about the roll kind of but
actually we care whether or not we add a
win or a loss and we just need something
that generated a winner or loss at the
odds of a 49 percent chance of winning
so let's go ahead and write that out
though just for kicks it's going to be
if roll equals 100 if that is the case
and in fact hold on since I'm going to
write some stuff out let me adjust the
size here real quick okay
if the roll is 100 we're gonna print
whatever the roll is hopefully it's a
100 we'll just print it for checking
purposes and we're gonna have it say
roll was 100 you lose what are the odds
play again okay
so if you roll 100 that's what's up and
instead of returning the roll let's just
have this return true or false so if you
won it's going to return a true and if
you lost it's going to return a false so
so if the roll is 100 we'll just return
false Elif roll is less than or equal to
50 then we print roll and roll was 1 to
50 you lose lose you nice you lose
again finally come down here l if um 100
is greater than the role yet the role is
less or greater than or equal to 50 so
basically what this means is if the role
is within 50 to actually hold on here if
the role is less than or equal to 50 so
0 to 50 we already have 100 we have so
actually this needs to be really greater
than 50 so 51 and on the next thing we
want to do so if this if this is the
case well then the user just won so
we'll say print role just for debugging
purposes and role was 51 to 99 you win
pretty lights flash play more okay and
then oh and we forgot our return false
here so come here return false and here
again we're going to return true because
this time the user won
scoot over now okay so now we have the
proper roll dice function and now let's
go ahead and create a very simple better
so with that let's go ahead and get rid
of this and then we're going to define
simple underscore bet tour and within
here we're gonna have a few parameters
what are the funds that this better
starts with what's the initial wager so
how large is this guy gonna wager and
eventually we might decide to change our
wage or increment the wager based on a
winner or loss and then finally wager
count how many wagers are we actually
looking to do here okay um so now we're
gonna say his value so how much money is
in his pocket well first it's going to
start off with however many funds we say
this guy has
but then later on value might change and
then wager so what's his current wager
well at least he's gonna start with the
initial wager and then here we're just
gonna have current wager and this is
going to mean like wager count basically
so current wager is zero and now what
we're going to do is Wow current wager
is less than wager count so while the
current numbered wager that we're on is
less than the total number of wagers we
intend to do we're going to do we're
going to roll the dice right so if roll
dice so basically what this is asking is
if true right so if rolled dice returns
a true this will this will run so if
roll dice value plus equals wager
so if roll dice returns a true that
means hey we rolled the dice and we won
so through our value our funds add the
wager because we just want else value
mine is equals wager because we just
lost then the next thing we're going to
do is a current wager plus equals one so
we just did a wager so we'll add one to
that counter and uhm I guess for
debugging purposes first will print
funds down here so print funds : um
value so we'll just do that once and now
let's go ahead and call simple better so
simple underscore better and our
parameters again we have funds how much
money we can start with we'll say we'll
start with 10,000 uhm the initial wager
sighs let's do $100 each and how many
wagers do we want to do for now let's
just say 100 so we'll save that and
let's go ahead and run it and let's just
read through some of our results just to
be sure that our math is doing what we
actually expect it to do so
we lost so we lost 100 makes sense we
lost so we lost 100 makes sense we ones
we gained 100 makes sense
we lost lost lost levels
so we won pretty lights 95 okay so
anyway after 100 bets just for kicks
let's see where we stand
8800 we actually did pretty poorly even
though we had 49% ons so anyway close
that so simple better not doing so hot
but that was only one reality so again
like let's run it though again and let's
see now this guy actually this dead guy
did even worse 8000 this is another
reality right so even though you might
only play as a simple better once one of
these outcomes can be yours but you
wouldn't get both of these outcomes
surely somebody will profit I'm just
trying to find us a profit there we go
this guy profited right he ended with an
actual profit does that mean his his
strategy was a good strategy
no but generally that's how we value
people is based on their profits not
necessarily their strategy which is
interesting because statistically there
must be people who are highly profitable
just based on odds so it's actually kind
of interesting so anyways we're going to
see a lot more of this and then we'll
soon we'll see you know with a pool a
large pool of people how this works so
anyways stay tuned for the next video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time